So to avoid the space complexity in the
Anderson's array based queueing lock, we're going to use a
linked list representation for the queue. So the size
of the queue is going to be exactly equal to
the dynamic sharing of the lock. And this particular
linked list based queueing lock algorithm is due to
the authors of the paper that I've prescribed for
you in the reading list. Namely Mellor-Crummey and Scott.
And so, sometimes this particular queueing lock is
also referred to as the MCS lock. So the
lock data structure. The head of the queue is
a dummy node. It is associated with every lock
so every lock is going to have this dummy
node associated with it and will initialize this dummy
node to indicate there is no lock requesters presently
for this particular lock. So, this pointer is pointing
to nil. Nobody's got the lock. And there are two
fields for every q node for a requester. So every new
requester is going to get this q node. And in this q
node there are two fields. One field is the guarded field.
And guarded is basically a bullion that, which, and, and it
says whether I have the lock or not. If it is
true, I've got it. If I don't have, if, if it
is false I don't have it yet. And the next field
in the queue note is pointing to my successor
in the queue. So if I came in and I
requested the log, I get into the queue. And if
a, if a successor comes along and requests a log,
he gets queued up behind me. So that's this
basic data structure, every queue note Is associated with a
requester. The dummy node that we start with is representing
the lock itself. And since we are implementing a queue,
fairness is automatically assured. The requesters get
queued up in the order in which they
make the request, and so we have fairness
built into this algorithm, just like the Anderson's
array-based queue lock. The lock to, to
nil indicating there are no requests yet. And
let's say that I come along and request a lock. I don't have to wait because
currently, there's nobody in the queue and therefore I get
the lock right away. And, and I can go off
into the critical section and start executing the critical section
code, that is associated with this particular lock. So what
I would have done, when I came in to make
this lock request. Is to get this q node. And
make the lock data structure point to me. And I'd
also set the next pointer to null, to indicate there's nobody
after me. And once I've done that, I know that I've got the lock. And
I can go off in the critical section, and do whatever I need to do.